so hello and welcome before we start
today's midday briefing we have a
statement from Commissioner for digital
economy and society maria gabriel who's
here today to talk to you about the
entry into force of the cybersecurity
act thank you and good afternoon
everybody two major issues today cyber
security and artificial intelligence or
AI let me start but the fact that
tomorrow is an important day the cyber
security act comes into force it's
important for us in European Commission
too because we've been able to combine
speed with quality over the past two
years and bringing forward this act it's
an issue of a supreme importance for
European citizens and for us in Europe
as well so that's had just less than two
years ago president Yonko announced a
robust set of measures aimed at
enhancing our ability in the EU to
defend cyberspace so as I said tomorrow
the Cyber Security Act which is a
regulation it's the cornerstone of this
package in fact will come into force
this cybersecurity package has a number
of key elements first of all a new
permanent and enhanced mandate for any
CERN and the director is mr. odo is here
today you've done a lot of work you've
provided us with a lot of know-how
within Anisa as well and you've got
these new tasks now of enhancing
cybersecurity further if we look at the
new regulation well basically this means
that Anisa can help Member States to
increase their national capacity and
European capacity as well Anissa will
also contribute in setting up a
cybersecurity certification scheme in
Europe this is a new European level
certification exercise which allows
companies to certify the product once
only their certificates will then be a
valid rather across the EU
this means that we can reduce time and
costs involved in obtaining us a
certificate across the member states
this will encourage people to go for a
certification we hope and enhance both
the resilience and the competitiveness
of the internal market in the area of
cybersecurity it's also important for
consumers for European citizens because
they will know the level at which
security corresponds to whatever they're
purchasing now what comes next to the
Commissioner is going to launch a an all
stakeholder call to create a group of
experts for certification we are going
to initiate consultations with a view to
preparing the union's work program this
work program was set up priorities for
certification for the coming years now
with the cybersecurity act once it's
come into force will then have the
proposal for the European competence our
Skills Center for cybersecurity now this
is a proposal which as you know has
already been debated during to try Logue
sessions with both European Parliament
and the council we will be working
towards a political agreement on this
file by the end of October in addition
to cybersecurity ladies and gentlemen
I'm also happy to be able to announce
new developments to you today with
regard to our European strategy for the
development of artificial intelligence
in April we welcomed the fact that the
conditions were in place for in
artificial intelligence centred on
humans and worthy of trust this was a
set of guidelines proposed by our
high-level expert group now the group
has also suggested an evaluation list of
a practical nature to allow parties our
stakeholders to verify whether the
principles in the guidelines
comply with these conditions so from
today on companies and all of other all
of the other stakeholders will be in a
position to test the actual
implementation
in reality of this evaluation list so
call upon everybody involved in AI to
share their experience with us and to
get involved in this pilot phase which
will continue until December we are
talking here about very useful
information because the analysis will be
in a position to be presented at the
beginning of 2020 all the information on
this initiative can be found on the
Alliance for artificial intelligence
platform this morning I welcomed more
than 3000 participants in this Alliance
because they've done a fantastic piece
of work in less than a year in parallel
to this we'll have a series of case
studies worked on by the expert group
with a view to more in-depth analyses as
I pointed out already on the basis of
these analyses which will take place at
the beginning of 2020 we will be able to
revise the suggestions from the
high-level group because a number of
these ideas may have to be fine-tuned or
adapted others will remain unchanged
others would probably be enhanced or
stepped on further and look after the
incoming Commission then to suggest what
we do further secondly and here once
again today the expert group has
submitted its recommendations to the
Commission with regard to its policy
actions and the investments needed with
a view to exploiting to the maximum all
the possibilities offered by these new
technologies now we're going to analyze
these new recommendations and they were
feedin to the work which has already
been initiated with the member states
you may remember that in December of
2018 we published a coordinated plan
together with the Member States we are
going to use this to be able to be even
more precise when it comes to our
proposals for the coming steps now I'll
stop there thank you for listening to me
and I will now attempt to answer any
questions you may have
ok we've got